نعم قبل قليل وصلت اربعه عشره شاحنه من
الامم المتحده الى ساحه معبر باب الهوى
هذه هي الشاحنات التي تظهر الان في
الكاميرا تحمل
مستلزمات خيام ومساعدات انسانيه للمتضررين
من الزلزال وهذه المساعدات سوف يتم نقلها
الى داخل الاراضي السوريه الى مستودعات
الامم المتحده
داخل الى مستودعات المنظمات الشريكه مع
الامم المتحده داخل محافظه ادلب
وحتى ثم بعد ذلك يتم تسليمها الى
المتضررين والمشردين من ضحايا او من من
الذين تصدعت بيوتهم والذين دمرت بيوتهم
ويعيشون الان في مراكز ايواء كبيره
ما تزال هذه الشاحنات متوقفه هنا في معبر
باب الهوى يتوقع ان تتحرك في اي لحظه كما
يظهر هي تحمل يبدو ان هذه الشاحنه تحمل
على مواد غذائيه
وبعد قليل سوف تتحرك الى داخل سوريا لكن
حقيقه هذه المساعدات لا تحوي على اي من
المعدات التي تساعد على رفع الانقاض او
انتشال العالقين تحتها تحتها كما
وفق النداء الذي وجهه الدفاع المدني
السوري لانه لان متطوعيه يواجهون صعوبات
كبيره في رفع تلك الانقاض وتعبت فرق
الدفاع المدني خلال ايام الماضيه حقيقه
وما تزال هناك الكثير من اكوام الدمار
مكدسه هذه المساعدات اذا لا تساعد في عمل
فرق الدفاع المدني يبدو ان هذه الشاحنات
ستبدا بالتحرك وقد بدات فعلا دخلت هذه
الشاحنات الان او تدخل الى تعبر الجانب
السوري من معبر الهواء لتدخل الى الاراضي
السوريه الى مستودعات
المنظمات الانسانيه الشريكه مع الامم
المتحده
وستتولى هذه المنظمات توزيعها وفق اليه
ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه من معبر باب
الهوى التي يقرها مجلس الامن الدولي وفق
ما تعمل به عاده او الاجراءات المعمول بها
عاده في الاراضي السوريه وفي داخل محافظه
ادلب مساعدات ستصل الى المتضررين من
الزلزال الذين ما زالوا مشردين او يعيشون
في مراكز ايواء مؤقته تحمل مستلزمات خيام
واغطيه وعوازل للخيام تساعد العائلات على
التخلص من البرد او التخفيف من البرد وسط
درجات الحراره
منخفضه التي تسود هنا في المنطقه اخر
شاحنه تحركت قبل قليل واتجهت الى طريق
معبر باب الهوى المؤدي الى داخل محافظه
ادلب وايضا ارى وصلت قبل قليل ايضا شاحنات
لو نطلب من الزميل المصور ان يحرك
الكاميرا باتجاه الاخر هذه شاحنات من
منظمات تركيه وصلت قبل قليل ايضا تحمل
ايضا مساعدات للمتضر